afterthe an ass wiped out half of all
life in the universe
he finally rested at knowing that he had
brought balance to the galaxy in his
mind the survivors of the snap would be
able to flourish and they would not
become victims of overpopulation down
the line
however after catching brief glimpses of
what the world looks like now in the
recently released Avengers and game
Super Bowl trailer it's pretty clear
that earth is not the paradise that the
villain envisioned instead there lies a
vast blanket of cloud over New York
several ships Kelly bitty island and no
one is going to baseball games anymore
which is arguably the worst thing that
could ever happen but why does the
planet look like this and does it
showcase that Dan ass actually failed
well it's pretty clear to me they did
Dallas's plan on the surface seems
simple but it doesn't carry any logic to
it that would allow for life to grow
this is because in wiping out half of
all life which has been confirmed
directly by marvel he merely got rid of
a huge number of things but still kept
the ratio at one to one the plan would
have worked if Danis had only killed say
half of mankind
however he killed half of plant life
animals and bacteria so for example the
amount of trees left are unable to
properly process all of the carbon
dioxide on the planet into oxygen so now
we're left with a vast blanket of cloud
over everything animals that are eaten
have been harmed so the lack of food has
led to advanced starvation and with less
insect life vegetables and fruits are
unable to be carried and fertilized with
half of mankind missing - there are a
lot of essential job roles that have now
been abandoned and thus the industry
that creates food water and more is now
gone in an instant the galaxy's
carefully constructed ecosystem
completely vanished and thus the
survivors are left to suffer of course
this massively sets the stage for the
Avengers to get revenge and save the
planet had this devastation not happened
that they may have simply adjusted to
the planet grieved and moved on however
this definitely amps them up and makes
sense from a storytelling perspective to
show that Dan Ashe was indeed not right
this will ultimately lead to a bigger
payoff with the Avengers now
saving all life in the galaxy and serve
just cursing us to go back to
overpopulation to me it's an extremely
smart move and obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on it if you still
think that oz was right or has this
changed you mind
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown on the super bowl trailer
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]